course we no longer use the
gun we use the uh obviously
the tracking the puck now exactly so here's Austin
Matthews and again he's not really a slap shot guy
per se as well well he shoots him pretty good off
the one time on a slap shot but the hardest shot
we've seen from him all season is 991.43 in a
game well behind some of the big guns I think
the average fan would probably be surprised
by that he uses angles and he pulls the puck in
position and positioning and knowing that goalie
awareness when you're when you're G that there he
goes again 96 you got behind that one well invol
his game average that's very good again top speed
for him all year in a game is 991.43 he goes all
the way up to 962 guci don't forget there this
is a lot stick related a lot of these guys don't
have really stiff sticks they use a lot of whip in
their stick so they can get it off quicker without
is much power but in this competition you could
get you could get your manufacturer like bow to
give you a little stiffer stick to get more on
we we should get PK and and down there asking if
these guys change their Flex now M can bring it oh
boy he's not very he's not very far behind Pon for
top speed and highest average oh that's going to
be hard to beat 17 shots this year during games
with at least 90 m per hour that's the most of
anybody being a defenseman he's going to have
more Slap Shot opportunities every time I see him
he looks like he's getting bigger and stronger oh
yeah so 102 56 a nice lead as Matthews Falls to
Second David poast again more of a skilled
shooter like Austin Matthews how much power
can saying you know have when I talk about goalie
awareness it's about what when you're when the
pugs coming to you you see where the goalie is
moving from and you're shooting a back against a
grain or into corners and sometimes it's not
how hard you shoot as go where you're shoot
it again we have to start talking about the
cut line as the competitions go on was pasta
9328 again not quite the same power of a Pon
and marar but that's what I'm saying that he
could have just as much power but the stick the
shaft on the stick is a different release point
so that has a big factor in this competition
would be curious if any of these guys try to
stiff reflex for this yeah that was you could
tell he got that one more purely and it was 9
5.27 you like going in a long drive contest
instead of using your regular size Shaft or
length shaft there you get you another three or
4 inches on it there long as you can square it up
it's going to give you a lot more momentum
on the swing so so ma holds on to his lead
comfortably you see live standings if he could
take this competition he'd be up to 11 again
you want to make sure you make the cup but also
accumulation of these points to get that1 million
prize Miller's got a bomb Oh Miller's a big strong
kid [Music] mhm I'll tell you one or two that's
he's 1800th of a second behind see if he can top
that and get in front of K Mar we'll have one more
chance to do it Miller oh didn't get that one
but a good effort from JT Miller currently in
second to kale marar as Elias peton we mentioned
this is the clear favorite highest Top Shot speed
of anybody in the group during games this season
defending Champion see if he can top 102.5 6 you
think can can reach 103 misses he did last time
as defending champ 103.2 we'll see I you know
it's him yeah I know we've seen him do it before
so I would be surprised bam no I didn't get that
one one more [Applause] shot it's interesting in
this harder shot you got to hit the ice behind the
puck in order to load that shaft okay and if you
miss at it and don't time it properly you're not
going to get the velocity as we saw there he the
98 is not what he normally would shoot this Puck
at this one will be better that was his first shot
in this competition under 100 in his young career
bam he didn't get that either you could tell just
you know sometimes shank him right M time for him
that's a shank for you and I be shanking a
little more than he is currently in third
with three Shooters to go all right our current
leader K he knew right away he he didn't time
he's your winner so just five were in this
competition Kell Mard takes the over all lead
PK suban yeah guys kale marar here kale are you
surprised or did you expect to win this event oh
I didn't expect to win it I some of the boys told
me I should go in it so figured I'd never take a
run and started a puck before so I might as well
try it rumor has it that you Chang the flex on
your stick were you doing any uh fixing with the
stick before the event nothing before the event
I got a pretty stiff stick so I think that gives
me a little Advantage so and last question you're
so you're such a great skater you do it all like
how are you so good everybody wants to know how
are you such a great hockey player this early
in your career oh that's a loaded question I'm
not good enough to beat McDavid today though so
um yeah I don't know about that we'll take that
one and we'll move on well not too many are good
job K Mar hardest shot in the world right now